Merhabalar Öncelikle Ülkemizde yaşanan
deprem felaketinde hayatını kaybeden
herkese Allah'tan rahmet yakınlarına da
bahsini aldığını diliyorum Ben de
bölgeye İyi ki varanla arama kurtarma
ekiplerinden birindeydim ve günlerce
bölgede enkazaltı çalışanı olarak görev
aldım Bu yüzden bu etkinliğin gelirini
depremdedirlere bağışlayan Tetik
sayesinde Öncelikle ardından zamanınızı
ayırıp buraya geldiğiniz için sizlere
çok teşekkür ediyorum
[Alkış]
Ben güntülü Yalçın 3 Ekim 1993'te
Ankara'da doğdum
lise öğreniminin sonuna kadar
Ankara'daydım ardından şeyle beraber
üniversite ile beraber dünyayı keşfetme
gezme görme merakım başladı Daha
sonrasında kısaca bir dönem İstanbul'da
yaşadım
ama daha doğrusu Aslında Uzunca bir
dönem yaşadım ama hep gezdiğim için çok
nadir İstanbul'da bulundum Daha
sonrasında İstanbul'un Kaos durumundan
sıkılıp zaten doğayla iç içe yaşayan
biri olarak bir gecede Fethiye'ye
taşınma kararı aldım ve sonra üç buçuk
yıldır burada yaşıyorum
profesyonel dağcıyım aynı zamanda
otostopla dünyanın 36 ülkesini
Türkiye'nin ise 81 ilinin tamamını
gezdim
başarı ve daha doğrusu insanların
genelde başarı olarak adlandırdığı
benimse kendime keşif yolculuğu olarak
adlandırdım bazı şeyler yaptım bunları
da böyle kısaca bahsetmek istiyorum
kantingri de ana tırmandım 7010 metre
yüksekliğinde benim tırmandığım yıllarda
en genç Türk kadın Dağcı ünvanını
almıştım benden sonra benden daha genç
bir kadın arkadaşımın tırmandı Ağrı
Dağı'na bir kaç kere çıktım Hatta
bunlardan birinde doğuştan yüzde yüz
görme engelli Melisa'yı Ağrı Dağı'na
çıkararak ilk defa Ağrı Dağı'nın
zirvesinde bir görme engellinin Zirve
yapmasına birlikte Tanık olmuştuk
kazmekte anlatırım Anladım
Gürcistan'da Hakkari'de ciro Dağları ve
daha önce Zirvesi yapılmamış bazı
dağların ilk tırmananı oldum
Nahçıvan'ın Hac adına tırmandım Karabağ
sınırında 0 noktasında birdaydı ve
bölgenin kritikliği sebebiyle daha önce
hiç tırmanılmamıştı Biz de hem
karabağ'daki şehitlerimizden bak
amacıyla hem de Türkiye dağcıları olarak
Azerbaycan'a verdiğimiz desteği
göstermek amacıyla açıdan da ilk defa
bir tırmanış gerçekleştirmiştik
Mersin'den Kıbrıs'a kano ile geçtim daha
önceki geçiş rekoru 32 saatti Biz 27
saatte 100 kilometrelik parkuru
Mersin'den Kıbrıs'a çıkarma limanına
girerek kırmış olduk Çok güzel bir
tecrübeydi Bu da
haricinde Tara kanyonu Dünyanın ikinci
büyüklerinin Nehir kanyonu Grand
kanyonu'ndan sonraki Türkiye'de de bir
kanyona bunu söylüyorlar Ancak bu bilgi
doğru değil doğru olan tarakan yanı
bunun kış geçişini yaptım Bunun
haricinde de Türkiye uluslararasındaki
birçok küçük daha büyük daha
Türkiye'deki bütün dağlara istisnasız
şekilde neredeyse tırmandım o yüzden Tek
Tek bahsetmeyeceğim
ilgi alanlarım da genellikle ahşap
işçiliği hariç hep ekstrem sporlar var
Çünkü ben kendini ekstrem sporlarla
bulmuş biriyim aslında
9 yaşında Ankara Barış İzci grubuyla
başladı Benim doğaya olan merakım
ardından orada böyle küçük küçük
uyanışlar Yaşadım ve bununla beraber 16
17 yaşında Türkiye'den avcılık
federasyonundan almaya başladığım
eğitimlerle ilk defa 18 yaşında
profesyonel bir daha tırmandım
O yüzden bugün sizinle Bulutlara aşmayı
konuşacağız Benim adım güntülü Yağmur
yağdıktan sonra Güneş açınca incelen
Bulutlara deniyor görüntülü ve ilk defa
hayatımda bulutları aşarak kendimi
keşfettiğim hikayeyi anlatmak istiyorum
size ilk profesyonel tırmanışım kaç
kardeşdi ve Kaçkar böyle bulutlarıyla da
biraz ünlü bir daha gece zirveden
yürümeye başladığımızda bulutlar böyle
üstümdeydi ve görebiliyordum aradan 5-6
saat geçti böyle hava bir ara çok soğuk
oldu çok sisli çok nemli oldu ve hava
artık aydınlanmaya yakındı zirveye de
son böyle bir 200 metre falan kalmıştı
ayakta Mola verdik böyle bir dönüp
arkama baktığımda manzaraya bakayım
dedim ayakta Mola esnasında o bütün
bulutların tamamen altında serili olduğu
sahneyi Hayatımda ilk defa gördüm ve
benim çocukluk hayalimdi Aslında
bulutların üstüne ev yapmak Çocukken de
bulutlarla yakından ilgiliydim
ve böyle ilk defa yürüyerek bulutların
üzerine çıkabildiğimi keşfettiğim bir an
vardı orada Evet dedim ki ben yürüyerek
bulutların üzerine çıkabiliyorsam her
şeyi yapabilirim bu benim için gerçekten
büyük bir kırılma noktasıydı aslında
yani size de tavsiyem daha sonra
nacizane tavsiyem hayatınızdaki o
anların Eğer farkına varırsanız
gerçekten İçinizde yatan başka bir
insanın varlığını ilk defa keşfetmeye
başlıyorsunuz ve keşfettikçe artık bunun
üzerine giderek daha da mutlu bir insan
olmayı daha sevdikleriyle var olmayı
seven bir insan olmaya başarıyorsunuz
ben kendim açısından en azından bunu
başarabildim diyorum Bununla ilgili de
sevdiğim bir söz var duvar inek için bir
sınırdır fakat kuş için değil bir şeyi
senin için sınır yapan sahip olduğun
yeteneklerdir
birçoğumuz Aslında yeteneklerimizin ne
olduğunu bilmiyoruz 18 yaşında iken ben
de yeteneklerimin ne olduğunu neler
yapabildiğimi gerçekten bilmiyordum
çünkü toplumun bize direttiği bazı
şeyler var böyle işte çok iyi bir
arabayı binmeyi işte binmenin sizi mutlu
edeceğini söylediği için iyi bir arabaya
bindiğimizde birçoğumuz mutlu olduğumuzu
zannediyoruz Çünkü toplum böyle söylüyor
ama İçinizde bir yerde bunun gerçek
olmadığını bir noktada biliyorsunuz ama
toplumdan dışlanmamak için Çoğu zaman
bunu yapmayı yani Sevdiğiniz şeyi ve
sizi sen ya sizi siz yapan şeyi
keşfetmeye çıkmıyoruz bir çoğumuz bunu
yapıyoruz Ben de 18 yaşında bir kız
çocuğuyken aynı bunu yapıyordum bugün 30
yaşından Geriye baktığımda Evet 12 yılda
çok fazla şey sığdırdım bu 12 yıla
otostopla 36 ülke Türkiye'de 81 onlarca
da çok farklı deneyimler işte çok farklı
köyler kültürler sığdırdım
ve bunun için evet bu bana hayata dair
bir vizyon kattı
birçoğumuz sürekli şunu söylüyoruz
kendimizi Bir zamanlar ben de çok
söylüyordum ya ben onu yapamam ben
böcekten korkarım ben yüksekten korkarım
ben oraya gidemem ben bunu yapamam
burada bir anam eki var yapamamla yapmam
arasında tek harf var arkadaşlar ama
bunlardan birisi size sınır koyarken
diğeri tercih ettiğiniz bir şey oluyor
Hiçbirimiz burada daha tırmanmak zorunda
değiliz Evet ama ben daha tırmanamam
demek kendine güvensizlik ve kendine
inançsızlıkken Ben de atarım anlamam
Çünkü bundan mutlu değilim demek ne
istediğini bilmek bu iki arasında Bu
ikisi arasında ciddi bir fark var o
yüzden Kendi içinizde arada bir yastığa
kafaya koyduğunuzda Şöyle bir düşünün
Ben neyi seviyorum Ben neyi yapamam
değil yapmam ben nereye gidemem değil
gitmem bunlarla kendinize sorup
kendinizle sohbet etmeyi öğrendiğinizde
kendinizle var olmayı da öğreniyorsunuz
aslında
Buraya böyle bir düşünce bulutları
şeklinde koydum konumuz Bulutlara aşmak
Çünkü aslında ve birçok karikatürde de
böyle insanların düşüncelerini
Bulutlardan çıkartırlar ve bulutlar
genelde hep bir sınırdır Mesela işte
uçaklar Bulut tavada kalkmazlar
paraşütçüler bulutlu havada uçmazlar Biz
bulutlu havalarda tırmanmıyız hep bir
sınır ne zaman ki bu sınırları aşmayı
başarabiliyoruz ve kendimize olan
inancımız artıyor İşte o zaman gerçek
bizle tanışmaya başlıyoruz Benim kendime
olan keşif yolculuğumda
otostopla 36 ülke Türkiye'de 81 il nasıl
oldu konusu çok soruluyor Bana
inanın ben dünya turuna çıkmaya karar
verdiğimde Muhtemelen bu salondaki
herkesten daha fakirdim ve Param yoktu
Sadece babadan yeşil pasaportumu vardı o
yüzden vizeselli bir problem
yaşamıyordum ama şu an günümüzde birçok
ülke zaten vizesiz
Takip ettiğim yabancı bloglarda bir
kadın gördüm otostopla dünyaya geziyordu
ve bana ilham oldu bugün Umarım ben de
size ilham olabilirim bu konuda dedim ki
Neden Ben de bunu yapamıyorum ki
dünyanın bir noktasında bir kadın bunu
yapıyor ve ben de Türkiye'de doğmuş bir
kadın olarak Evet bunu yapabilirim
otostopla çıkıp Türkiye'den birçok
ülkeye seyahat edebilirim dedim ve ilk
otostop çekme deneyimimde böyle birazcık
çekingendim Ben de herkes gibi ama o
Elimi bir kere kaldırdığımda ömrüm
boyunca geri indiremeyeceğimi o gün ben
de bilmiyordum gerçekten ve Bugün sadece
şunu yaparak 36 ülkeyi görmeyi başarmış
biri olarak buradayım
ya birçok alanda Aslında konforumdan çok
vazgeçtim çadırda yaşamayı öğrendim
hatta çok uzunca yıllar neredeyse doğru
düzgün yatakta yatmadım sürekli çadırda
yattım Bunun haricinde işte şelalelerde
duş aldım ki orada Belli fotoğrafları
var bunların zaman zaman bisikletle bir
yerlere seyahat ettim bazen işte Koç
Surfing uygulamasından benim misafir
edecek insanlar buldum Hatta bazen onu
da bulamadım o insanlara sadece tek
ricada bulundum 5 dakika evinizde bir
duş alıp çıkabilir miyim dedim bir çoğu
kabul etti dünyanın birçok noktasında
sizi misafir edecek yüzlerce insan var
aslında çok mu iyi dil konuşuyordum yurt
dışına çıkarken Hayır yani ben ortalama
bir İngilizce ile gittim ki çok çok iyi
İngilizce biliyorsanız dahi gittiğiniz
birçok ülkede size cevap verecek
insanlar zaten İngilizce konuşamıyor ama
biz de genelde şöyle bir algı var ya ben
değil Bilmiyorum nasıl gideceğim ben
işte yol bilmiyorum Nasıl yapacağım
Yani aslında yola çıktıktan sonra yol
size bir şekilde ne yapmanız gerektiğini
ya da sizi bir noktaya götürüyor ve her
şey akışına bıraktığınızda o
sınırlarınızı algılarınızı toplumun
dışına açtığınızda her şey çok daha
farklı oluyor
Bunun haricinde bazen paramın bittiği
zamanlar oldu hatta bir kere yurtdışında
bayağı hastalanmıştım ve cebimde
gerçekten Türk Lirası olarak hesabımda
İşte 23 TL falan gibi bir rakam yanında
da 13-14 dolar gibi bir para vardı ve
ülkeme dönmek isteyecek olsam dönecek
bilet param bile cebimde yoktu böyle ne
yapacağım diye düşünürken cosford'de bir
aile benim misafir etmeyi kabul etti
İşte hastaneye götürdüler 2 hafta
boyunca bana baktılar ve ben Babamı
arayıp Baba ben çok hastayım ve şu an
dünyanın bir ucundayım bana bir uçak
bileti alır mısın desem 5 dakikada o
bileti alacaktı Ama ben aramamayı tercih
ettim Çok Çünkü bu benim kişisel
yolculuğumdu bu aslında dünyayı keşfetme
merakımdan öte bir yere ait olma Ve
kendimle var olma çabasıydı bu yüzden
aramamayı tercih ettim ve yoluma devam
ettim günlük işler buldum birinin Market
raflarını düzenledim temizlik yaptım
ambarlarda çalıştım vermeye gittik
yaptım Hemen hemen buldum günlük para
kazanabileceğim her işi yaptım çünkü
süper egomla barıştım Evet ben her şeyi
yaparak sevdiğim şeyleri de aynı zamanda
yapmayı sürdürebilirim mi keşfettim ben
tuvalete temizlemem Diyebiliriz ama yeri
ben tuvalet temizledim ve bunun
karşılığında bir ülke daha fazla
görebildim Bu da benim hayatımda çok
fazla şey değiştirdi
Tolstoy'un bisikleti diye bir kavram var
işinizde Belki daha önce duyan Vardır
Tolstoy Bisiklet sürmeyi öğrendiğinde 67
yaşındaydı ve bugün günümüzde Hayatta
hiçbir şey için geç kalınmış olmadığını
gösteren bir cümle Bununla ilgili kısa
bir hikayem de var Bir günün akyakadan
Marmaris otostop çekerken
çok böyle gerçekten iyi bir araba bir
Porsche önünde durdu ve beni aldı
içerisinde gerçekten Belli ki biri
oturan bir arabaydı arkada çünkü önünde
şoför kullanıyor arkada birisi oturuyor
gidene kadar sohbet muhabbet ettik böyle
hoşuna da gitti Beyefendinin
varmış Akşam işte kızı ve eşi de
gelecekmiş biz de bir yemek yer misin
diye ricada bulundu kızımla tanışmanı
isterim dedi işte otostop hikayelerimi
anlattım vesaire O da benimle aynı
ülkelere Gitmiş ama gittiği ülkelerde
işte hemen hemen aynı ülkelere gitmişiz
gittiği ülkelerdeki sadece farklı
hiltonları görmüş Aslında farklı Hilton
Gezileri yapmış bir beyefendi
aynı ülkelerde Benim anlattığım yerleri
duyduğunda baya şaşırdı orada böyle bir
şey olduğunu bilmiyordum Aa orada odamı
varmış oldu Daha sonrasında iki günlük
birlikte geçirdiğimiz zaman sonrasında
tekrardan
ayrılma aşamasına geldiğimizde artık ben
Datça'ya devam edeceğim iki gün
tekmelerimde benim misafir ettiler çok
güzel vakit geçirdik ve gitmek istediğim
herhangi bir ülke için sponsor olmayı
teklif ettiler çok büyük holdinglerden
birinin sahibiymiş beyefendi bunu da
ikinci günün sonunda öğrendim O
zamanlarda Rio karnavalına gitmeyi çok
istiyordum O yüzden neleri yok Karnavalı
olur mu dedim olur dediler bütün
masraflarımı karşıladılar ve beni oraya
gönderdiler geldikten sonra bir teşekkür
Telefonu açtım ve bir daha hiç
konuşmadık bir yıl sonrasında telefonum
çaldı ve aynı Beyefendinin beni
aradığını gördüm ve Şaşırdım vallahi
Allah Dedim acaba neden arıyor yani dedi
ki biz geçen sene hani seninle tanıştık
bu sene dedi ben kamp yapmak istiyorum
ve çadırda kalmak istiyorum Bana bir
malzeme listesi gönderir misin Ne
olmalıyız önce bir ciddiye alamadım
çünkü hani öyle birinin kamp yapıyor
olması biraz enteresan geldi tamam dedim
bir malzeme listesi gönderdim Hemen
aldılar malzemeleri ve buluştuk
Daha sonrasında kamp yapmaya başladı
birlikte bir kamp yaptık bundan sonra
alplere gitti yürüyüşler trekkingler
yapmaya başladı ve zaman zaman beni
arayıp hala teşekkür ediyor 65 yaşında
gerçekten Milyoner olan bir insan bile
65 yaşında 23 yaşındaki otostopçu kızdan
öğrenciye bir şey vardı bu hayatta ben
de Hayata hep böyle bakıyorum Benim de
Herkesden her zaman öğrenciyim bir şeyi
var diye bakıyorum
burada Bazı fotoğraflar koydum Bunlar
benim hayat serüvenimde karşılaştığım
bazı güzel Ruhlar en son fotoğraftaki
tekerlekli sandalyedeki Çağla doğuştan
engelli ve tekerlekli sandalyesiyle
otostopla Türkiye'yi geziyor
bu yukarıdaki fotoğraftaki Yiğit işte
ben evliyim ama çocuğum var ama gezemem
artık Bizden geçti yani yüzlerce kadın
arkadaşım var yiğit otostopla bir yıl
boyunca bizim kucağımızda çadırda büyüdü
ve bir yıl boyunca otostopla gezdi
bir an fotoğraftaki Mustafa abi bir
avukat çocukken 5 yaşında çocuk felci
geçirmiş birisi Ancak o fotoğrafımız
Allahu ekber daha zirvesinde çekildi
Sarıkamış anlatırım bana şimdi Mustafa
Abi koltuk değnekleriyle 150'den fazla
Zirvesi olan birisi
en üst fotoğrafta Melisa ile çekilmiş
Bir fotoğrafımız var orası da Ağrı
Dağı'nın Zirvesi doğuştan %100 görme
engelliydi Melisa ama Ağrı Dağı'nın
zirvesinde Zirve yapmayı başardı bir alt
fotoğrafta Hasan amca var atasından
kalma olan mağara evlerine Türkiye'de
elektrik ve su aboneliği almayı Başaran
tek kişi kendisi bir mağarada yaşıyor
Çünkü atasından kalma bir mağara orası
hatta internet bağlantısı bile var şu
anda Yani aslında ya sınır dediğimiz şey
hep zihnimizde Bu yüzden bu sınırları Ya
ben yapamam bu insanlar çok fazla şeyi
başarıyorlar ama bir yani sağlam
bedenimizle çoğu zaman kendimize
zihnimizde sınırlara oturttuğumuz için
sürekli ya onu yapamayız ya böyle olursa
ya Öyle olur sanırla yaşıyoruz
Ben Fethiye'ye taşındığımdan beri
dünyadan gördüm vizyonla beraber iki
şirket kurdum kendime bir İspanya Ajans
diğeri pione Turizm
birinde seyahat acentası işletmeciliği
diğerinde ise dijital pazarlama
hizmetleri veriyorum dünyayı görmeseydi
Muhtemelen buna cesaret edemezdim Ama
gördüğüm için en azından buraya
geldiğimde de çok söyleyen oldu niye
bunu yapıyorsun git bir yerde çalış gibi
aynı zamanda uluslararası anlamda yat
alım satımı yapan Bella Things isimli
bir firmanın Genel Müdürlüğünde
yapıyorum 3 işte birden çalışıyorum ama
şu an 3 işimi de çok severek yaptığım
için her sabah yataktan kafamı
kaldırdığımda geçmişte yaptığım şeyler
için önce kendime teşekkür ediyorum ve
her gün severek gittim ve çok severek
yaptığım bir işim var o yüzden
yaptığınız her şeyi sevin
ve bir gün bir noktada beni
hatırlarsanız kendinize sürekli şunu
tekrarlayın arkadaşlar Uçun kaçın
bulutları aşın
kafanızdaki tüm sınırları bırakın ve
gerçekten Ne istediğinizi kendinize sık
sık sorun bunları yapmaktan çekinmeyin
Ben de çok hata yaptım ben de çok yanlış
yaptım Fethiye'ye taşınmaya bir gecede
karar aldım ve 48 saat sonra
fethiye'deydim bundan 4 ay sonra pandemi
başladı ve ben Fethiye'de İşsiz kaldım
Pekala babamın evi var Ankara'ya gidip
dönebilirdim ama yine de dönmedim
ahşaptan bir şeyler yapıp Instagram'dan
sattım kiramı ödedim Ve yine Fethiye'de
kalmaya devam ettim Ben yaptıysam
Aslında 48 kilo bir kadından sizin daha
da fazla yapabileceğiniz şeyler var
sizin potansiyeliniz Belki de benden
daha yüksek sadece kendinizi
keşfetmenizi Beklediğiniz bir nokta var
Onu bulmanızı rica edeceğim nacizane
teşekkür ederim beni dinlediğiniz için
bugün
[Alkış]
[Müzik]